este problema dice resta expresa la
diferencia en su forma más simple muy
bien vamos a empezar restando cuando
tenemos números para poder hacer una
suma o resta de fracciones necesitamos
encontrar un denominador común lo mismo
sucede con las expresiones racionales
aquí tenemos dos denominadores que se
parecen tienen como términos parecidos
pero no son iguales entonces necesitamos
igualar estos denominadores para poder
hacer la resta es decir tenemos que
encontrar una expresión que sea tanto
múltiplo de este denominador como de
éste tenemos que encontrar el mínimo
común múltiplo de ambos denominadores
vamos parte por parte empecemos con los
números ese mínimo común múltiplo debe
ser múltiplo de 7 y de 3 así que debe
ser múltiplo de 21 entonces aquí debemos
de tener 21 y acá también ahora vamos
con la m tiene que ser divisible entre m
cuadrada y entre m pero basta pedir que
sea divisible entre m cuadrada porque
con eso ya tenemos que es divisible
entre m así que aquí voy a poner una m
cuadrada y aquí también y con esto nos
hacemos cargo de él
constantes y de la m ahora vamos a ver
qué sucede con la n aquí tenemos n a la
1 el exponente aquí es 1 aquí n a la
cuarta y de manera similar como elegimos
con las ms aquí basta con pedir que sea
divisible entre n a la cuarta entonces
aquí yo voy a poner n a la cuarta y acá
también n a la cuarta y listo con esto
determinamos nuestro denominador común
este ya es múltiplo de este denominador
y de este denominador vale entonces
ahora lo que tenemos que hacer es
ajustar los numeradores déjame ver por
cuanto multiplicamos para pasar de este
denominador a este de acá entonces el 7
lo tuvimos que multiplicar por tres la m
al cuadrado simplemente se queda como m
cuadrada y la n se tuvo que multiplicar
por n al cubo en el cubo entonces lo que
hicimos fue multiplicar el denominador
por 3 n al cubo y para preservar la
expresión el numerador también tiene que
ser multiplicado por 3 n al cubo
bueno haciendo esta multiplicación 3 por
6 nos queda 18 y 18 y además hay que
poner m n al cubo m n al cubo muy bien
ahora déjame hacer con este color rosa
el segundo término vamos a ver por
cuánto multiplicamos los denominadores
en este caso aquí el 3 para pasar a 21
se multiplicó por 7 la ms multiplicó por
m para llegar a m cuadrada y a la n no
le tuvimos que hacer nada entonces aquí
arriba multiplicamos por 7 m de modo que
aquí abajo también hay que multiplicar
por 7 m
y entonces el numerador nos queda 7 por
5 35 35 por mn al cubo por m n al cubo
ya estamos listos para hacer la resta
déjame escribirla aquí abajo voy a
utilizar estos mismos colores
entonces nos queda 18 m n al cubo 18m n
al cubo menos 35 m n
- 35 a eso esta interesante m n al cubo
/ / / 21 m cuadrada n a la cuarta ya
terminamos pues todavía no aquí arriba
todavía podemos restar estos términos
porque tienen los mismos exponentes la m
y la n así que básicamente aquí hay una
aquí hay que hacer un pequeño ejercicio
de restar números tenemos 18 de algo y
estamos restando 35 de ese mismo algo
entonces cuánto nos queda saber 35 menos
18 es 17 pero el 35 tiene menos y el 18
más entonces nos queda menos 17 menos 17
m n al cubo m n al cubo simplemente
realizamos la resta y eso hay que
dividirlo entre este denominador entre
21 m cuadrada n a la cuarta y ya casi
terminamos porque todavía podemos
simplificar un poco esta expresión de
igual 17 es primo entonces no se va a
poder cancelar con nada pero aquí la m y
la n pues todavía se puede simplificar
un poco
nos quedaría menos 17 está m se puede
cancelar con esta m cuadrada y abajo nos
queda m está n al cubo con la n a la
cuarta de abajo simplemente abajo nos
queda n así que queda menos 17 dividido
entre 21 21 m n y entonces este numerito
de acá menos 17 entre 21 m n es la
respuesta para nuestro problema